OF THE HEALTH ASSESSMENT
CHILDREN RECEIVE WHEN THEY COME
INTO CUSTODY.
NOW THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
REASONS FOR PEOPLE TO LEAVE
THEIR HOMES TO START A NEW LIFE,
GANG VIOLENCE, PANDEMIC FUELED
POVERTY AND THE AFTERMATH OF
NATURAL DISASTERS, WHILE
PLAYING INTO MIGRANTS DECISIONS
TO LEAVE.
MATT RIVERS IS JUST BACK FROM
HONDURAS WITH SOME OF THEIR
STORIES.
>> JOHN, WE'VE SPOKEN TO A LOT
OF MIGRANTS ONE-ON-ONE OVER THE
PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS
ESPECIALLY HERE IN MEXICO.
MIGRANTS COMING FROM CENTRAL
AMERICA AND WE HEAR THESE
CONSISTENT STORIES, THERE'S A
LACK OF OPPORTUNITY, THERE'S
CHRONIC VIOLENCE, THERE IS
CORRUPTION AND WE WANTED TO GO
TO ONE OF THOSE CENTRAL
AMERICAN COUNTRIES, GO TO
HONDURAS TO SEE EXACTLY WHAT
THOSE MIGRANTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
SPEAKING TO ARE TALKING ABOUT.
>> 2017 YEAR OLD WERE BORN IN
RAISED, AND ONE OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS COUNTRIES IN THE
WORLD THEY LIVE IN ABJECT
POVERTY BUT FOR THE BOYS IT IS
HOME AND THEY WILL MISS IT
BECAUSE THEY ARE ABOUT TO LEAVE
IN THE UNITED STATES.
AT THE BEDROOM THEY SHARED THEY
SHOW US THEIR NEW PRICE
POSSESSION THE BRAND-NEW SHOES
THEY WILL USE TO MAKE THE
MINIMUM 1500 MILE JOURNEY TO
THE U.S. MOSTLY ON FOOT.
>> I'M LEAVING ON THE 17TH WITH
THESE CLOSE HERE THAT THEY'RE
GONNA BRING WITH THEM.
>> HE SAYS THAT IT FEELS
TERRIBLE BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO
LEAVE MY MOTHER BUT WE HAVE NO
FUTURE HERE.
THEY WILL JOIN THE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF OTHER HUNDREDS WHO
STREAMED INTO THE U.S. THIS
YEAR LEAVING BEHIND ONE OF THE
POOREST COUNTRIES ON EARTH.
NORTHWARD MIGRATION ISN'T YOU
BUT THE CONDITIONS FORCING
PEOPLE TO NEW, ARGUABLY HAVE
NEVER BEEN WORSE.
STARTING WITH TWIN CATEGORY 4
HURRICANES THAT MADE --
2 WEEKS APART UTTERLY
DECIMATING THIS REGION.
PEOPLE LOST EVERYTHING IN HALF
A YEAR LATER, HARDLY ANYTHING
IS BACK TO NORMAL.
WE MEET A FAMILY WHO BUILT A
MAKESHIFT SHELTER ON TOP OF
THEIR OLD HOME AFTER IT WAS
COVERED BY MUD IN HURRICANE
FLOODING.
>> WE LOST EVERYTHING SAYS THIS
MAN I WANT TO LEAVE BECAUSE I
CAN'T FIND A JOB THERE'S NO
SUPPORT FROM THE GOVERNMENT.
AND JUST UP THE STREET, WE NEED
ANOTHER FAMILY, ANOTHER HOME
WIPED OUT DURING THE STORM.
WATER LEAK RIGHT THROUGH THE
WALLS OF THEIR SHELTER.
THEY SLEEP ON MATTRESSES THAT
ARE ON DIRT FLOOR IN A HOUSE
MADE UP --
WERE DESPERATE HE TELLS US WE
DON'T HAVE A CHOICE SAYING HE
WILL SOON BE FORCED TO MIGRATE
SOUTH TO.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT MORE
THAN 6 MONTHS AFTER THE MOB --
WHAT USED TO BE A HOUSE IT GOT
COMPLETELY FILLED UP WITH MUD
DURING HURRICANE, AND OBVIOUSLY
THE FAMILY THAT LIVED HERE
CAN'T COME BACK.
IN RESPONSE THE GOVERNMENT TOLD
CNN THAT THEY HAVE BEEN MAKING
REPAIRS GIVING US THIS VIDEO
SOME OF THEIR WORK, THEY SAID
REPAIRS LIKE THIS TAKE TIME IN
THAT BACK-TO-BACK HURRICANES
WOULD BE DIFFICULT FOR ANY
COUNTRY TO DEAL WITH, CRITICS
DOUGH SAY THEY ARE EFFORTS
HAVEN'T BEEN NEARLY ENOUGH.
MAKING THE RECOVERY WORSE, ALL
THIS DAMAGE CAME DURING A
DIFFERENT KIND OF STORM, THE
PANDEMIC.
COVID-19 RESTRICTIONS MEANT
UNEMPLOYMENT SOARED, HALF OF ON
DORIAN'S NOW LIVE BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE SAYS THE WORLD
BANK.
IF THEY HAD MORE OPPORTUNITIES
PEOPLE WOULDN'T HAVE TO LEAVE
THIS COUNTRY, SAYS THIS LOCAL
PRIEST.
FOR NOW THEY WILL TAKE THE TIME
THEY HAVE WITH EACH OTHER,
BECAUSE IN A FEW DAYS THE
ALWAYS WILL LIKELY END UP HERE.
A BUS STATION WHERE EVERY NIGHT
THE BUS LEAVES FOR THE
GUATEMALA BORDER, FROM THEIR
MANY MAKE A RELUCTANT WALK
NORTH, THE FAMILY OF 4 PLANS TO
DO JUST THAT.
>> [INTERPRETER]
WE CAN'T TAKE IT ANYMORE, THERE
ARE NO JOBS OR EDUCATION FOR
HIS KIDS.
HERE WE HAVE NO OTHER OPTION
BUT TO LEAVE.
>> SOME OF THESE NEIGHBORHOODS
WE WENT TO WERE EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS AND MANY PLACES WE
HAD TO LEAD LOCAL GANG LEADERS
KNOW THAT WE ARE GOING TO BE
THERE JUST SO THERE WEREN'T ANY
SURPRISES.
WE SPENT 5 OR 6 DAYS ON THE
GROUNDS AND I THINK ALL
POLITICS ASIDE, IF THERE IS ONE
THING THAT OUR TEAM TOOK AWAY
FROM THIS IS THAT IF YOU WANT
LESS MIGRANTS TO ARRIVE AT THE
SOUTHERN U.S. BORDER, YOU HAVE
TO GIVE THEM REASONS TO STAY.
JOHN?
>> CHRISTOPHER JOINS ME NOW
FROM LONDON HE'S A SENIOR
FELLOW, HE'S A PROFESSOR AT
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY.
CHRISTOPHER, REFLECTING ON THIS
PACKAGE YOU JUST SAW FROM MATT
RIVERS IT MAKES THE POINT YOU
HEAR FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, FROM THE NEEDS
TO ADDRESS ROOT CAUSES.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS WHAT ARE
THE ACTIONS THAT THE UNITED
STATES CAN TAKE THAT HAS PROVEN
TO BE ABLE TO STEM THE TIDES OF
THESE MIGRANTS?
>> FIRST OF ALL THAT WAS A GOOD
PACKAGE.
IT DOES INDICATE JUST HOW
SYSTEMIC THESE CHALLENGES ARE,
AND YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE SOME TIME.
THESE ARE QUESTIONS OF LACK OF
SOCIAL MOBILITY, LACK OF
OPPORTUNITY AND WITH THAT IT
COMES WITH VIOLENCE AND
INSECURITY THAT THE REPORT
TALKED ABOUT.
THESE ARE SYSTEMIC ISSUES.
THEY'RE NOT GONNA BE SOLVED
OVERNIGHT.
YOU HAVE TO FIRST OF ALL
ADDRESS GOVERNMENT CAPACITY,
AND THAT IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
YOU DO VERY QUICKLY AND TURN
AROUND.
THERE ARE DECADES IF NOT
CENTURIES OF GOVERNMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN INEFFECTIVE IN
DELIVERING EDUCATION.
INEFFECTIVE IN CREATING A
PREDICTABLE UNSTABLE
ENVIRONMENT THAT IS NECESSARY
FOR INVESTMENT AND JOB GROWTH.
YOU ALSO HAVE PROBLEMS IN TERMS
OF DELIVERING EDUCATION,
DELIVERING POLICE FORCES AND
SECURITY THAT PROVIDE BOTH THE
CONTEXT IN WHICH PEOPLE LIVE
AND PROVIDE THEM THE SORT OF
STABILITY THAT THEY NEED BUT
ALSO THE ABILITY TO TRACK JOB
AND INVESTMENT IN THE COUNTRY.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT THE
UNITED STATES ARE GOING TO TRY
TO ADDRESS, BUT IT IS GOING TO
TAKE MUCH MORE THAN THAT.
JUST THROWING MONEY AT THIS
PROBLEM, WHEN GOVERNMENTS ARE
SO AN EFFECTIVE, AND THEY IS
SUCH SKEWED INEQUALITY, OR
DISTRIBUTION OF RESOURCES IS A
VERY LONG TERM PROBLEM FOR
WHICH THERE IS NO EASY
SOLUTION.
>> THAT IS A VERY TALL ORDER AS
A MATTER OF POLICY, OF COURSE.
ANOTHER FACTOR THROUGHOUT THE
REGION IS POLITICAL REPRESSION.
I WANT TO TURN TO NICARAGUA.
JUST A TWEET FROM THE ACTING --
HERE IS WHAT SHE SAID.
HE WAS ARRESTED AND SHOULD
RESOLVE ANY REMAINING DOUBT
ABOUT OR TAKE US CREDENTIALS AS
A DICTATOR.
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY HAS NO
CHOICE BUT TO TREAT HIM AS
SUCH.
THAT IS TOUGH TALK FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
THE SANCTIONS ON ORTEGA'S INNER
CIRCLE ARE TOUGH ACTIONS BUT IS
IT ENOUGH WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH SOMEONE LIKE ORTEGA?
>> THAT IS EXACTLY THE
QUESTION.
SANCTIONS CAN TRY TO ATTEMPT TO
IMPOSE SOME PAIN ON THESE
INDIVIDUALS AND THAT IS WHAT
THE SANCTIONS ARE.
THEY'RE NOT SANCTIONS AGAINST
THE COUNTRIES PER SE.
BUT THOSE ARE TRYING TO TIGHTEN
THE LATITUDE FOR MOVEMENT IN
THE ABILITY TO GAIN RESOURCES
AND TRAVEL EVEN FROM THE
MEMBERS OF THE ORTEGA FAMILY
AND THOSE AROUND HIM IN
RESPONSE TO THIS OPPRESSION BUT
YOU ARE RIGHT WE CAN'T REALLY
MEASURE THE LEVEL OF CRUELTY
AND THE NEED FOR THESE
GOVERNMENTS AND OFFICIALS TO
STAY IN POWER.
FIRST OF ALL FOR AS LONG AS
THEY'RE IN POWER THEY HAVE
IMPUNITY, AND THEY KNOW DARN
WELL THAT THERE IS EFFECTIVELY
A PRICE ON THEIR HEAD.
ONCE THEY STEP DOWN FROM POWER
THEY WILL LIKELY BE ARRESTED IF
THEY TRAVEL, THEY WILL LIKELY
HAVE TO SPEND TIME IN JAIL FOR
THEIR CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY.
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO STAY IN POWER.
SANCTIONS SIMPLY ARE GOING TO
UPPED THE ANTE A LITTLE BIT.
THEY MAY IMPOSE A CAUSE BUT
WHAT WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
HERE IS SOME SORT OF DEFECTION
WITHIN THE GOVERNMENT OR PEOPLE,
THOSE AROUND ORTEGA, HE'S NOT
GONNA STEP DOWN EASILY FOR THE
REASONS THAT YOU SAY.
SOMEBODY SHOULD SAY, MY TIME IS
BETTER SPEND NOT WITH THIS GUY,
I'M JUST GOING TO BASICALLY
TURN HIM IN AND CHANGE
GOVERNMENT.
>> ALL RIGHT CHRISTOPHER
SABATI